whenever women like won't answer
questions like that it's always because
they answer that they would give us
incriminating ultimately at the most
basic level I think red pill is waking
up to the truth waking up to reality and
when it comes to intersexual Dynamics
it's waking up to perhaps uncomfortable
truths the reason I won't answer is
because of trauma and I don't want to
get into that it's something very
disheartening that's fine I've dated
this guy and he didn't have this thing
but usually he had something else like
even you know Molina like she'll say
well I'm not dating Destiny for his
money well you know we don't look at
what you say we look at what you do what
up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series today I am going to be
reacting to the whatever podcast you
know what's so funny I love this
psychologist I have watched his videos
before and when I saw he was on whatever
I was so excited open invite sir if
you're ever in London you know come out
so you're saying okay so then let's say
the girl gets into a relationship then
how do you determine her smv from the
guy status yes so I think that you can
kind of in this framework determine a
woman's sexual Marketplace value by the
normalized sexual Marketplace value of
the men who are willing to get into a
relationship with her and you can
determine a man's male sexual
Marketplace value by the normalized
sexual Marketplace value that women he
is able to sleep with
okay what if she's gay how do you
determine her smv I don't I don't know I
guess you could do it I think most of
these Concepts apply also to gay
relationships I don't know if lesbians
are hypergamous
uh they are really big on commitment
there's no joke about what does a
lesbian bring to a second date and it's
a trailer because she's moving in so
there there's takes all kinds but there
is a my understanding a big bet in
lesbian relationships towards commitment
I just feel like in high schools and
colleges like people kind of date people
at their school they're probably like in
a similar income range so I don't know
how you would determine like the smv of
like a college sophomore is doing
another College sophomore who are both
kind of an equal amount of college debt
and you wouldn't say she has low smv
because she's dating a guy in debt and
not getting scooped up by a Millionaire
right so it doesn't kind of make you
know the athletes kill in college or
like the musicians I mean there's like
certain guys on campus that are like
higher smv just like there's certain
women on campus that are higher smv too
I mean there is a guy that dated like
three girls on my team I mean you can't
tell me that he wasn't irrelevant to
most dating instances no because I think
it's based on the context in which you
exist so we can say that people might
have a normalized sexual Marketplace
value for the culture at large but maybe
the culture that in the context that
matters most to you is your campus or
maybe it's even just like the people in
your homeroom class like there's all
kinds of hierarchies within social
systems as soon as more than two people
start to relate to each other okay so
then you would then judge it based off
like okay is that guy an athlete is he
like doing well or like what would be in
high school yeah that's that's the
stereotypical one it's like who is the
Big Man on Campus is the quarterback
right sure now does this guy can he
compete with somebody who's 35 makes a
million dollars a year well it just
depends on who what the woman is looking
for you know she might be so involved in
that context that she will actually
choose the quarterback over somebody who
you know hundreds of thousand dollars a
year I think it really depends on the
context all right
um oh and one more thing and I think
this is why this is great advice for
guys uh especially maybe the shorter
Kings out there five seven uh is find a
context in which you can shine like you
can be a contextual Alpha I know you
might not love that term but you can
definitely have a higher sexual
Marketplace value in certain contexts
versus others so The Hobbit why should a
man shorter than his bloodline oh excuse
me shorten his bloodline for you besides
the two obvious reasons well thank you
um what is shorten his bloodline does
that means she's short you shouldn't
date tall women I mean I'm a little
biased you know what I mean but in my
family and my family that was very my
brother dumped women because they were
too short that actually did happen I
remember it was this girl he met in
college he's like God I really like her
she's so great she's got this this and
this but I just can't get over her
height I can't have short kids I'm a
little biased though you know what I
mean well I I mean they tall guys like
me but like I said it's not a deal
breaker that's true most men don't care
though that's like a that's a very
minute you know thing but also I'm worth
it so why not um why I kind of wanted to
come in I think on the 10 the one to ten
thing there so I mean you say that you
don't rape people based off of a
physical appearance how tall is the guy
that it's complicated with I actually
don't know I'm his tall whenever women
like won't answer questions like that
it's always because the answer that they
would give is incriminating not very
good at telling height so I'm oh my God
how tall you have to guess
um
maybe five nine six foot he's six foot
enough
um you don't care at all about his
physical appearance um
um I so I always ask can I say a picture
because girls will say oh
it's ugly
so I was asking okay let me let me see a
picture whenever I see the picture he's
not ugly he's never ugly I've never seen
a guy that is butt ugly he's attractive
for sure but well hold on I thought
everyone's equally attractive well no I
I did mention that I think there are
levels of Attraction but I think that
everyone is born beautiful in their own
unique way but are there some people
that you you don't find physically
attractive just say yes
yes I think in my personal preference
there are people that aren't as
attractive as others but I just I think
rating people just doesn't have any
value to you to it okay no I I
understand that would you say that there
are there are groups of people that you
find attractive that there's degrees to
those that you find attractive uh do for
example you could find two people
attractive but you find one more
attractive than the other yes
um do you mind clarifying A Little More
well I mean if there's hold on just a
sec thank you David Jackson donated 200
notice how I ask her how she's worth it
and her answer is because I'm worth it I
mean I could give the points I can
debate all night I did speech and debate
so I have the points ready what are the
points are you the table what do you
bring to the table the table you are the
table Yeah Okay so
what type of guy am I catering to
because it depends like I don't know I
feel like this podcast it goes for like
the red pill movement right so do you
want me to look I mean because I can't
answer I don't know if this podcast goes
for the red pill movement although I
have a are you sure some blue pills on
the table well I I don't I don't like in
the same way that I don't like the alpha
characterization the high value High
status man characterization I believe
that people can have differences of
opinions and I'd much rather just tell
you what my thoughts are than just try
to attach myself to like a given a given
movement movement
um I mean uh ultimate and the you know
look the red pill red pill space is uh I
suppose getting some Flack right now but
red pill is a metaphor I mean I don't
think there's a like a there's not a
Bible of the red pill that it's like
this if you're red pill this is exactly
what you believe in I mean there's
people that are red pill that I disagree
with on things ultimately at the the
most basic level I think red pill is
waking up to the truth waking up to
reality and when it comes to
intersectional Dynamics it's waking up
to perhaps uncomfortable truths about
what men want what women want what women
are attracted to anyways that's kind of
derailing the conversation he's he's
curious
um why should a man shorten his
bloodline for you besides the two
obvious reasons well I mean if he wants
to he will and I mean like I said
previous boyfriends are good and above
but that doesn't mean that I wouldn't
date somebody shorter I don't mind
dating somebody shorter but what do you
bring to the table as well but you don't
mind it's different than you prefer okay
and this is what will happen girls will
be like oh well I've dated this guy and
he didn't have this thing but usually he
had something else like even you know
Molina like she'll say well I'm not
dating Destiny for his money well you
know we don't look at what you say we
look at what you do and maybe he didn't
have money when you first met him but he
has money now and man look at that stuff
it's like because women we can sniff out
a guy that we think is gonna be a winner
that's like our that's like our number
one sniffer like we can just tell you
know and it sometimes it's not a winner
like we do date bonds we do do that but
he's usually like athletic status
there's something that guy has women do
not date men with nothing and so men
look at what we do versus what we say
because we can say damn near anything
and so a lot of girls will get triggered
they'll say well I would date a guy
short but you wouldn't prefer it and
that's the point asking okay so educated
ambitious do you think men care about
that no no but I was gonna say other
things
but he's asking what you bring to the
table and it's not
I would say for most men they those
that's not at the top of the priority
list in terms of what they would find
attractive about really loyal I have
feminine qualities low body counts well
didn't you just say you were masculine
no I mean we have both qualities in me
and I've been working on being more
feminine and trying to like be more
feminine okay and I am
can I can I add to the red flag list be
more feminine I became feminine there
are women that say that that I believe
so I would like to say there are
exceptions to this rule but the rule is
that they're full of oh my God
they're full of half the women that
say I became feminine they can't even
like point to what they did to become
feminine it's just like yeah I read some
books I listened to them some podcasts
now I am feminine in a lot of ways okay
so you bring loyalty you bring your
loyalty is good right that's a good
answer low body count low body count
what's your body count
prefer not to answer you have a low body
count yeah I mean I don't sleep around
and I've only been like very few
relationships and the reason I won't
answer is because of trauma and I don't
want to get
it disheartening that's fine huh yeah
something's telling me she doesn't have
a low body count I mean that's just my
my guess you know
um so loyalty low body count any
anything else
um well I want to have children can you
bench press 200 pounds
will you stick it out in the zombie
apocalypse yes do you know how to play
the cello I don't but I know how to play
piano that's a deal breaker for Davon
Jackson I'm sorry if you don't know how
to play the cello it's a done deal okay
so going back to our thing one to ten
um so you were asking me to clarify when
it comes to I was asking you if you were
to find for example three men physically
attractive would you be able to for
example say he's more attractive than
this one and this one's more attractive
than the other
um yes I would be able to like or maybe
they would all be attractive sure it
would depend for example perhaps there's
a hundred people in the room say 50 of
them are men you could to some degree
put them in order of you could maybe say
that's the most attractive guy in this
room there could probably be guys that
were more attractive but maybe some
would be kind of equally attractive yeah
certainly there could certainly be
comparable physical attractive and
likewise you might see a few men in a
room who you find unattractive maybe
less attractive who you're not attracted
and you could say to some degree that
there's degrees to how not attracted to
them you are yeah I do agree with that
okay so I mean the one to ten scale
system is basically that she's saying
it's subjective so like if you go to
music an art museums you could say all
these paintings are beautiful but
there's certain ones that I'm more drawn
to you can rank all the paintings we can
still acknowledge that they're all yeah
but if all the women are drawn to the
same ones look it I understand we we
have types okay so you know some women
might be more drawn to you know the top
20 of paintings in the museum than
others but it doesn't change the fact
that we all kind of Select for the same
things and that's what I'm saying as a
Christian to understand that beauty is
objective like even in the Bible it
talks about the Bible records saying
that Sarah was beautiful yeah you know
Rachel is more beautiful than Leia you
know Esther that's a good well that's
why she was chosen by the king because
she was so beautiful yeah um so it's
okay like it's okay if we're not all
tens it's okay if you know if we're
honest about that because it does help
appreciate you know objective Beauty we
can appreciate it without feeling
devalued by it but it's not objective
because you take all the tens in one
city and bring them to a room full of
Victoria Secret models and every guy
would agree that their rating goes down
so how is it objective that is a really
good point Sorry I think it is
subjective though there are objective
traits like women
across the okay that's the stupidest
argument I've ever heard so okay that's
like me saying it's not objective who is
good at basketball because I was the
best in my hometown but if I go to a
WNBA game then I'm not the best anymore
um that doesn't make it subjective that
just makes it you went into a better
room so you know you you might still be
you know a 9.5 rounded 10 but if you go
to the nine point you know nine nine
nine nines if we're gonna you know break
it down that into that small of
increments you know now you don't look
as good but you still are what you are
you know or find taller men you know
more handsome if they've got a wider
jawline sharper jawline that's more
attractive to them you know wider
shoulders broader shoulders that's
attractive because those are all signs
of high tea high testosterone levels so
biologically women across the board
whatever country you want to go to women
are attractive attracted to things about
men that show that they're good leaders
strong providers strong protectors and
so it's a biological thing like it's not
a shallow you know conceited vein thing
and in the same way men also have you
know traits that they seek in a woman
because it communicates to them that she
is feminine that she can carry a child
because men really want procreate and
have children and carry on their
bloodline and so they want women who
objectively have wider hips and Fuller
breasts and things like that that sign
gives a sign of fertility and so it's
okay like it's okay to be biologically
wired it's okay to have a history as a
human race you have preferences men and
women both have preferences and the
subjective part I think that's a great
thing because if you're 411 if a man is
five five or just five foot tall that's
perfect for you you know because he's
still taller than you because he still
communicates protected protection and
provision to you so that's the
subjective part but there are biological
traits yeah there's a subjective part
like if you walked around UCSB because
we're in Santa Barbara and went to like
the hottest guys that you see csb and
then you like they're a 10 to the people
that live here and then you ask like the
most beautiful movie stars or whatever
Tick Tock people whoever you want to
bring if they're a 10 they wouldn't say
that because they're just like average
looking people like it just depends who
the audience is true but isn't it kind
of just trying to be kind of politically
correct when you're just trying to say
that oh like you know everyone's
beautiful like you're you're just trying
to not answer the question you're trying
to leave but the harsh reality is is
that like attraction matters it was the
hottest trick to you in this case most
attractive out of these five I would say
the one beside one one white oh in the
corner no no the one between the white
and blue yeah in the corner that well
that's the corner of the table it's so
interesting the girls that like guys
would pick versus their girls girls pick
because who I would pick wouldn't have
been the same way but it's so
interesting I'll actually say two of
them the one in White and the one beside
her I already said the one in White and
the one oh but but it's interesting
because what I've noticed is when girls
pick the most attractive in a room and
when guys pick the most attractive in a
room like they're never the same like
it's always been picked for different
things little creatures and women also
they do go based on attractiveness even
though obviously they're gonna lean more
into like personality and in the full
package but the reality is is that
people are gonna look at how you
attraction is different to everyone like
you could think someone is a 10 out of
10 and I look at them and I'm like I
would never talk to them today I'm just
thinking like what her saying I would
never talk to someone in my life is a
I mean okay nevermind that's mean
anyways guys
um you know that psychologist with bass
I I really like whatever podcast I think
they're doing great things their panels
are amazing but let me know what you
guys think in the comments like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel and I'll talk to you next time